?
>> Reporter: YEAH, THAT'S THE
SHERIFF OF UVALDE COUNTY.
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING NOW IS THAT
ACCORDING TO THE TEXAS
COMMISSION ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ALSO AN EXPERT THAT WAS
HIRED BY THE UVALDE COUNTY TO
REVIEW THE POLICIES OF THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE ON THAT DAY, WE
DISCOVERED THAT THE SHERIFF
ACCORDING TO THESE RECORDS HAS
NOT ACTUALLY HAD ANY KIND OF
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING.
WE ALSO LEARNED TODAY THAT ON
THAT DAY, ON MAY 24th, AND
REALLY FOR SEVERAL MONTH AFTER
THAT, ANDERSON, THAT THE UVALDE
COUNTY SHERIFF, THERE WAS NO
ACTIVE SHOOTER POLICY IN PLACE
AT THAT TIME.
THAT HAS SINCE CHANGED.
THEY INSTITUTED A POLICY IN
SEPTEMBER.
HARD TO BELIEVE ALL THIS
INFORMATION IS JUST NOW COMING
FORWARD.
WE ALSO TRIED TO GET INFORMATION
FROM OFFICIALS, FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL, WHO WAS
PRESENT ON THAT DAY OF THE
SHOOTING AND THE UVALDE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHO WAS
RUNNING THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
SHE HAS REFUSED TO ALLOW
INVESTIGATOR TO ANSWER ANY OF
THESE QUESTIONS AND OF COURSE
ALL OF THIS FAMILIES TODAY
EXPECTING TO GET SOME KIND OF
ANSWERS AND THEY DIDN'T,
ANDERSON.
>> THE MISSION NOW, SHERIFF.
>> YEAH.
ONE BY ONE, THEY'RE GOING TO
FALL.
>> Reporter: JUST OVER SIX
MONTHS SINCE THE ROBB ELEMENTARY
SHOOTING, FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS GATHERING IN FORCE AT
THE UVALDE COURTHOUSE.
>> I DON'T TRUST ANYBODY AT THIS
POINT.
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN INFORMATION
FROM ANY OF THEM.
OUR INFORMATION HAS BEEN COMING
FROM YOU GUYS.
>> Reporter: THEY'RE STILL
DEMANDING WHAT FAILURES ALLOWED
THE 19 CHILDREN AND TWO TEACHERS
TO GO WITHOUT HELP FOR MORE THAN
AN HOUR WHILE THEY WERE TRAPPED
ALONE WITH A GUNMAN.
AT A COUNTY COMMISSIONERS
MEETING, A HIGHLY ANTICIPATED
INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF THE LOCAL
SHERIFFS OFFICE REVEALED THE
DEPARTMENT HAD NO ACTIVE SHOOTER
POLICY AT THE TIME OF THE
MASSACRE.
>> THERE WAS NO ACTIVE SHOOTER
POLICY.
THERE WERE ONLY DEFINITIONS.
IT DID DEFINE WHAT ACTIVE
SHOOTERS WERE AND THERE WERE
FORCES THAT WERE CRITICAL
INCIDENTS AND HOW OFFICERS WOULD
RESPOND TO THAT, BUT THERE WAS
NO ACTIVE SHOOTER POLICY.
>> THE REPORT DID NOT EXAMINE
THE ACTIONS OF THE OFFICERS AND
THEIR FAILURES THAT DAY.
ONLY THE POLICIES THAT WERE IN
PLACE.
LAST WEEK, A CNN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE DEPARTMENT'S LEADER,
REVEALED THE HIGHEST RANKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN THE
COUNTY FAILED TO ORGANIZE A
RESPONSE.
EVEN AFTER HE WAS INFORMED OF
911 CALLS FROM INSIDE THE ROOM
ASKING FOR HELP.
HE SAYS HE DIDN'T HEAR THAT CALL
EVEN THOUGH BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE
SHOWED HE WAS IN EARSHOT OF
MULTIPLE RADIOS AND WAS TOLD BY
ANOTHER OFFICER ON SCENE.
THE SHERIFF GAVE INCORRECT
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT TIME HE
ARRIVED AT THE SCHOOL AND WHAT
HE COMMUNICATED TO OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS.
HE DID NOT APPEAR AT THIS
MEETING AND HAS NOT RESPONDED TO
CNN'S REQUEST FOR COMMENT.
SPEAKING IN NOVEMBER, HE SAID HE
THOUGHT HIS RESPONSE WAS
ADEQUATE.
SOMEONE WHO DID MAKE A RARE
APPEARANCE SPEAKING ONLY BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS, THE UVALDE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
CHRISTINA MITCHELL IS BLOCKING
ANY RECORDS OR VIDEO FROM BEING
RELEASED WHILE HER INVESTIGATION
IS ONGOING.
HER REASONING IS WEARING THIN ON
THE VICTIMS' FAMILIES AND THE
UVALDE MAYOR, WHO SUED THE D.A.
LAST MONTH, ASKING A JUDGE TO
COMPEL THE RELEASE OF
INFORMATION TO THE CITY.
MITCHELL HAS SAID HER
INVESTIGATION COULD TAKE YEARS.
SHE CONTINUES TO REFUSE TO
ANSWER CNN'S QUESTIONS.
ALSO APPEARING PUBLICLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE A CNN
INVESTIGATION INTO HIS ACTIONS,
MARIANO PARGUS.
HE WAS THE ACTING CITY POLICE
CHIEF ON THE DAY OF THE
SHOOTING.
A CNN INVESTIGATION REVEALED HE
HAD DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PHONE CALL AND CONFIRMED THE
DETAILS WITH THE DISPATCHER AND
STILL FAILED TO ORGANIZE HELP.
>> ALL THAT STUFF ISN'T THE WAY
IT HAPPENED.
>> I'M FROM CNN.
WE SPOKE ON THE PHONE.
SO, YOU'RE SAYING --
>> WE NEED TO GO.
>> YOU'RE SAYING SOME OF THE
STUFF OUT THERE IS NOT ACCURATE
SO I'M ASKING WHAT THAT IS.
>> Reporter: HE RESIGNED BEFORE
THE CITY COULD FIRE HIM, BUT IS
STILL UVALDE COUNTY
COMMISSIONER, A POST HE WAS
RE-ELECTED TO IN NOVEMBER.
AFTER THE MEETING, ANGRY PARENTS
WAITED OUTSIDE.
>> YOU'RE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO ASK YOU
QUESTIONS.
DO YOU THINK THE JOB YOU DID
THAT DAY WAS ADEQUATE?
>> EXCUSE ME.
EXCUSE ME.
>> ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY TO
THE VICTIM'S FAMILIES?
ANYTHING YOU HAVE TO SAY?
>> SHUT UP -- I HOPE YOU ALSO
TAKE CARE OF HIS KIDS!
I HOPE SO!
>> ONE WAY OR ANOTHER, YOU'RE
BEING FORCED OUT!
>> TALKING ABOUT MY SON --
>> SHIMON, HOW IS IT POSSIBLE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THIS
DAY AND AGE, I MEAN, SO MANY
YEARS AFTER COLUMBINE, THAT HE
WOULD NOT HAVE AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
POLICY.
I DON'T THAT.
THEY DIDN'T GO THROUGH ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING?
>> SO SOME OF THEM DID GO
THROUGH TRAINING.
THE SHERIFF DID NOT GO THROUGH
THE TRAINING, BUT INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH, ANDERSON, WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND IS THAT IT'S NOT REQUIRED.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
REQUIRED.
CERTAINLY LEGISLATORS, COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HOPE THAT CHANGES.
IT IS MANDATORY FOR SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS AND CHIEFS FOR
SCHOOLS, BUT NOT FOR POLICE
OFFICERS IN GENERAL.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT AFTER SO
MANY YEARS POST COLUMBINE THAT
THE SCHOOLS THAT SOME OF THESE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS DON'T HAVE
THIS POLICY IN PLACE.
MANY OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
DO THE TRAINING, BUT IT'S A
QUESTION OF POLICY AND WHAT'S
BEING TAUGHT TO SOME OF THESE
OFFICERS IN THESE SMALLER
DEPARTMENTS AND QUITE HONESTLY,
ANDERSON, IN TALKING TO SOMEONE
TONIGHT, THIS PERSON REALLY JUST
FEELS THAT THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE,
OTHER OFFICIALS THERE JUST NEVER
THOUGHT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WOULD HAPPEN IN THEIR TOWN.
>> STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN SENIOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST, ANDREW
McCABE.
YOU HEARD SHIMON'S REPORT.
NO ACTIVE SHOOTER POLICY IN
PLACE AT THE TIME OF THE
SHOOTING.
TODAY, THE UVALDE COUNTY SHERIFF
HIMSELF HAS NOT COMPLETED ACTIVE
SHOOTER TRAINING.
JUST FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
HOW IMPORTANT IS HAVING A POLICY
IN PLACE?
>> FOR ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THIS COUNTRY OF ANY
SIZE TO NOT HAVE AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER LAW ENFORCEMENT, ACTIVE
SHOOTER RESPONSE POLICY IN PLACE
OR PLAN IN PLACE IS JUST SIMPLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT MALPRACTICE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERSHIP
MALPRACTICE.
THERE ARE SO MANY RESOURCES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND AT
MULTIPLE STATE LEVELS TO PROVIDE
THAT SORT OF GUIDANCE AND
TRAINING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE RESULT OF MASSIVE
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS.
THE INVESTIGATIVE ASSISTANCE
CRIMES ACT FROM 2012 POURED
RESOURCES INTO IT.
THE FBI'S BEEN OUT DOING ALERT
TRAINING.
ADVANCED LAW ENFORCEMENT RAPID
RESPONSE TRAINING FOR A DECADE
NOW.
IF YOU GO ON TO THE DHS WEBSITE,
YOU CAN SEE THE MASSIVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXECUTIVE TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THE LATEST
INFORMATION, THE LATEST RESEARCH
AND TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY LINE
UP TRAINING FOR THEIR FOLKS.
THERE'S NO, IT'S INEXCUSABLE.
>> AND ANDREW, YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS.
AFTER COLUMN BIEN, CHANGED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT POLICY WAS
CHANGED TO GO IN IMMEDIATELY.
WHOEVER RESPONDS FAST, TEAM UP,
GO IN, NEUTRALIZE THE SHOOTER.
THAT'S JUST UNIVERSALLY
ACCEPTED.
IT'S NOT AS IF THINGS HAVE
CHANGED EVERY SINGLE YEAR IN
WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS.
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE NOW FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
>> IT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER A
DECADE.
THE ONLY THING THAT CHANGES FROM
YEAR TO YEAR IS THE NUMBER OF
MASS SHOOTINGS WE HAVE AND THAT
NUMBER KEEPS GOING UP
DRAMATICALLY.
THE FBI PUBLISHES DETAILED
RESEARCH AND REPORTING ON THAT
AND IN FACT, THE TEXAS
LEGISLATURE DID PASS A LAW
REQUIRING, AS SHIMON INDICATED,
A RAPID RESPONSE AND ACTIVE
SHOOTER RESPONSE TRAINING FOR
NOT JUST SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS,
BUT SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS.
SO ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
WHO IS ASSIGNED AND PROVIDING
SERVICES TO A SCHOOL AND THAT
COULD CERTAINLY INCLUDE OFFICERS
IN COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
OR CITY POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY ARE, THAT, THE TRAINING
THEY PROVIDE AND I HAVE IT RIGHT
HERE, IT'S AVAILABLE ONLINE FOR
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO READ IT.
IT'S A FASCINATING DOCUMENT.
IT PERFECTLY TRACKS THAT
STATE-OF-THE-ART WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT STANDARDIZED RESPONSE.
THE PRIORITIES OF WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN YOU SHOW UP
AT THE SCENE EVEN IF YOU'RE THE
ONLY PERSON.
THE FACT YOU HAVE TO PUT
YOURSELF AT LIFE'S RISK IN ORDER
TO TRY TO STOP THAT SHOOTER FROM
KILLING INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
ALL THAT STUFF IS RIGHT THERE IN
THE POLICY.
>> SHIMON, WHEN IT COME TO THE
UVALDE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
CHANGING, WHAT'S CHANGING?
>> SO, THIS POLICY IS NOW IN
PLACE.
THERE'S A POLICY, YOU KNOW, THIS
REPORT TODAY, THIS ALL COMES
BECAUSE THERE WAS A REPORT, THE
COUNTY HIRED SOMEONE, THEY DID
THIS REPORT, THEY DID NOT FOCUS
ON ANYTHING, ANY OF THE FAILURES
THAT DAY.
INSTEAD, THEY SAID WE'RE JUST
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POLICY, BUT THERE ARE STILL SO
MANY QUESTIONS AS OUR REALLY
LONG INVESTIGATION PROVED LAST
WEEK, ABOUT THE ACTIONS OF THE
SHERIFF.
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WANT HIM
OUT OF OFFICE.
HE'S ELECTED SO IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT, BUT ALSO THE ACTIONS
BY THE DEPUTIES AND WHAT THEY
WERE DOING.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
OFFICIALS KEEP REFUSING TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE SHERIFF HAS REFUSED TO
WE'VE GONE BACK TO HIM TODAY TO
FIND OUT IF HE HAS ANY RESPONSE
TO THIS REPORT.
NOTHING.
AND THAT'S WHAT KEEPS HAPPENING.
SO WE DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S NO TRANSPARENCY.
AND QUITE FRANKLY FOR THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AN KIDS WHO GO
TO THESE SCHOOLS IN UVALDE,
THEY'RE AFRA